ask what did you say you're a doctor
right yeah
what is your stance on this and
especially in the hospital like because
obviously we're talking about nurses and
Etc so I just wanted to know what you
it's it's difficult I mean you know
clearly the majority of doctors at the
moment in May all that's mainly because
of the older Generations the majority of
medical students and young doctors are
female sort of switched around
that's part of the reason this is so
complicated is because we're often
measuring people of different
Generations so I honestly don't know I
think probably from anecdotes from my
own experience or my reading of the data
there are ways that women get screwed
over in the job market than men the men
don't there will be some the other way
around I don't know who is worse off
overall than it it's a